prenez soin de votre communauté
vous êtes dans la partie du pays qui n'est
plus contrôlée par le gouvernement
des États-Unis les garçons je vous aime tous
les deux tuez ce morceau ils ont foiré avec la
mauvaise famille comment cela s'est-
il passé il y a une nouvelle classe d'arme tout
s'est déconnecté jamais  est revenu, y compris
le commandement central américain, j'étais censé
dire que je vais combattre tous ceux qui veulent
se joindre, il est le bienvenu pour les
laurie
et nous créons le chaos dont nous avons besoin pour voler
cette arme,
nous héritons de notre liberté maintenant c'est à
nous tous de  bats toi
pour eux c'est juste un endroit pour
nous c'est notre maison